foreign
okay
um so our next speaker is Ludwig Schmidt
he's an assistant professor of computer
science at the University of Washington
he's done a lot of impactful work on
distribution shift and more recently
data quality and so today he'll be
telling us about his data Centric
perspective on generalization
option and thanks a lot of for staying
until the end I know this is the last
long part of the workshop and it's
Friday but yeah happy to be here and uh
basically a month ago
Umesh sent me an email they want to come
to the structure and I thought like yes
definitely this is all super exciting so
the goal of the workshop is to try to
understand the ongoing revolution in
Transformers and large language models
from our Wildlife so like okay I'm
definitely on board with the revolution
part there has been a ton of progress in
AI over the past 10 years and then chat
GPT came out end of last year and since
then even more crazy a lot of exciting
things going on the point of the
workshop description where I wasn't so
sure about it the ongoing revolution in
Transformers and large language models
and this basically touched on a question
I'd been thinking about for a while are
the Transformers really necessary in all
of us right this is as the description
He suggests this is usually seen as a
revolution thanks to the Transformer
architecture and the part that we
figured out large language models are
really important resource right and at
some level you may say
our Transformers will be Central to this
the answers obviously yes this is maybe
a bit of a stupid questions because
they're literally everywhere an AI
Machinery right now if you take a step
back and you look at natural language
processing computer version speech
processing and so on over the past five
years basically all of these fields have
ripped out the existing architectures
and have put and Transformers so they
are clearly a very powerful tool GPT the
most popular language model is actually
a Transformer just by name channel 23
Transformer the Transformer paper is
very impactful they checked 86 000
citations and there are also just some
very clear advantages of the
architecture it has efficient Hardware
implementations it allows you to unify a
lot of different modalities like text
emergency speech actions and Robotics
and so on allows you to handle long
sequences
but I still think it's an important
question to ask would all of the
revolution in language modeling have
happened if we had never discovered the
Transformer I think this is a good
question to ask because if this is the
case what does this tell us about
progress in AI
and in order to answer this question or
at least to try to attempt to answer
this question for today we look at a
perspective from scaling sites
um since it's day five on a workshop on
large language models fortunately by now
everyone has read about scaling laws and
scaling Trends yeah someone gave a very
nice talk on this so yesterday I just
decided to steal her slides from YouTube
um right the high level idea of the
scaling Trend scaling laws as they're
kindly discussed and deep learning is we
would like to predict the performance of
a machine learning model as a function
of some basic quantities like training
data model size or amount of compute and
what people have found out via extensive
empirical studies over the past two
years is that
um four language models you can actually
do this very well you can predict the
test loss as a function of compute data
set size and parameters via plots like
this and this has become a really
important part of this puzzle for
training large language models because
that's nasal tests they are large they
take a lot of resources to train so you
can't just do a ton of hyper parameter
search for the very larger scales you
need to do a lot of your exploration on
smaller models and then there's missing
pieces okay I do all my small
experiments what does this mean if I had
trained a similar model at Large Scale
this is exactly what the scaling laws
allow you to rest okay cool and we are
going to look at one of the first let's
say modern papers on deep learning
scaling laws which is this paper here
from 2017 end of 2017. deep learning
scaling is predictable empirically and
this is a really awesome paper like this
is before GPT came out this was
extremely forward-looking so like if you
read the abstract it basically has all
of the keyboards that are super hot now
five or six years later so they already
said deep learning creates impactful
advances following a virtuous recipe
model architecture search creating large
training data sets and scaling
computation
and they say we would like a deeper
understanding of the relationship
between training set size computational
scale and model accuracy and they
already in the abstract state if fit
power loss the power loss works well
they talk about the slope of the
resulting scaling Trends and so on
um yeah I mean I really recommend
reading this paper as I said it's very
overlooking there's many good bits in it
and one nice experiment they did was
obviously on language modeling and
specifically Word level language
modeling which just means predict the
next word
and they experimented is the standard
experiment you train models of various
sizes with different hyper parameters on
varying training set size so here we
want to understand scaling as a function
of training set size and then you fill a
power law of this form so the error
light or perplexity is a function of the
training set size m is going to be Alpha
some parameter we're going to estimate
times m to the power B the scaling
coefficient plus some irreducible error
gamma we don't know alphabet a gamma
will estimate some data and then what
did they find
basically they found plots like this so
x-axis training set size this is a
subset of our data set called to billion
word data set so by the stanza standards
of 2017 a billion words was a lot now
the super consider tiny
um y-axis is your validation loss and
then they did this through for three
different networks two types of lstms
long short-term memory networks or type
of recurrent neural network this is a
classical architecture in terms of like
the state-of-the-art the current
architecture at the time in 2017 RH and
recurrent Highway networks and what they
find is overall You can predict scaling
quite well so you could say okay here at
the higher end so like high more data
end of the spectrum maybe this is
becoming a little bit of a worse fit but
they say in the paper as they explored
more hyper parameter choices that got
closer to the prediction and the problem
already at the time back then was doing
these larger scale experiments just
takes a lot of compute so there's a
hypothesis was if they had had more
computers would have met very closely
followed the line also for the larger
models and this was basically
qualitatively exactly the same picture
that people then figured out a couple
years later for Transformers right it's
coupling L paper which I just mentioned
um this is doing the same experiments
for Transformers and also found this
predictable scaling here
the exponents of all of these papers are
quite different
yeah so I mean the exponents may just
depend on the training set right
the only training sets are very much not
the same yeah no the exponents are
different um we go to a more direct
great question we get from one direct
comparison between the two in a minute
but for now I think just qualitatively
this like nicely predictable scaling
scaling of power loss was already there
and so different network architectures
have similar scaling Trends they already
figured this out themselves they say
Okay
um RH ends the recurrent Highway
networks have significantly different
recurrence structure than lstms but show
newly identical learning curves
okay and they had more cool experiments
in the paper so the next thing they did
was character level language modeling so
instead of predicting the text right now
we do a character level otherwise the
same story we train models on various
training set sizes power law of the same
form and then the results they got is
the following here they only look at one
architecture now RH ends Highway
networks from just now and we compare
SGD versus atoms so two different
optimizational algorithms and then their
takeaway again was okay
um Adam is Factor
um you need less training data but
overall these are pretty similar scaling
so if you're fine with making your model
a bit larger you don't really need to
care about SGD versus Adam it's a
basically just compute modifier
cool okay so this is what they figured
out in 2017 already and then in the 2020
paper now we're going to get through Rex
questing they also had some experiments
on Transformers versus
lstms specifically this plot here
um and now the nice thing is this is
controlling for data and so on the
x-axis parameters of the model y-axis
test loss Blue Line Transformers and
then if you have three different lines
here for lstms so when you look at this
now you may think okay this is a little
bit more messy here for the lstms the
one two and four layer they have
different scaling Trends the Transformer
line looks a lot more clean but then you
look at a different part of the paper
and you find exactly the same phenomenon
for Transformers so this is now only
Transformer scaling Trends one two three
six layers the one layer scaling trend
is quite different and with two you're
almost there kind of like the idea being
with many layers you reach a limit here
I think the fact that this is a little
bit messy you shouldn't like like this
is also going to happen for Transformers
the same phenomenon there and overall if
you say well you know it depends a
little bit how you look at this
I think it's pretty fair to say that if
you make this larger you will probably
continually stretch they didn't do this
because this wasn't the main focus but I
think this is overall also pretty good
evidence that if you push the lstms
further they will get you to the same
place as Transformers they may require
more data and compute
and in the paper to be fair here they
also clearly point out one weakness of
the lstms this is something people had
discussed for a while they made this
very nicely precisely with the
experiments
um the lstm specifically do worse on
later tokens in the context so this is a
plot here x-axis token and index in the
context y-axis the per token test loss
and then we have sort of like
three pairs of experiments here the red
line is lstms the blue line is
Transformers so Piet number of
parameters and then you can see that the
red line here the lstms plateau
significantly earlier than the
Transformers in terms of like reducing
the Tesla so probably reason for the gap
between transform and lstm performance
is here that the lstms do burst on
longer sequences
cool okay so we do one more architecture
comparison
and this is again from the Kaplan and
paper where they look at two different
Transformer variables recurrent or
sometimes they're called Universal
Transformers versus standard
Transformers
and again same story you can have it
look at different variants of the
recurrent Transformer and you will get a
little bit different sort of like
offsets here compared to the dashed line
the standard Transformer but overall it
looks like they have very similar scales
um basically you use the same parameters
over and over again as opposed to
different layers
okay so you may say this is all nice
good thing we're looking at some of the
papers but one thing we have learned
from discussing language models you
should not only look at text because if
you only look at text maybe we're just
being a stochastic parrot and we need
some grounding okay so let's get and I
thought okay let's get some more
grounded opinions and I just thought
okay let's ask the experts some people
actually train the gpts and the
Transformers or invented them what's
their opinion on this and the first
person I asked is Alec I like Radford
he's a research scientist at open AI he
actually invented GPT
that's his creation and so I thought he
will probably know well at least he has
an interesting take on this and he
basically said yes you will be on the
same LM trajectory without Transformers
we may need to do some more tweaks to
the rnns but overall the research
Community is really good at tweaking
architectures so probably not an
obstacles next person I asked actually
here at this Workshop is Lucas Kaiser I
don't think he is here today he was here
a couple of the things maybe you've seen
him yellow t-shirt super nice guy he and
what invented Transformers uh when he
was a Google now he said open Ai and he
was a little more ambivalent
um he said maybe but you may need 100
more 100 times more compute to match the
Transformers with the current networks I
think that's fair based on the plots
we've seen you may just need more
compute
and look as interesting he told me he is
a back and forth on this with India now
and then and local showed me Ilyas also
in the camp of yes this would just be
fine but
you may need a very large certain state
so yes it's an engineering challenge the
Transformers are almost certainly more
compute efficient but there's nothing
fundamentally different here that we
would get the same high quality language
models that we just use
[Music]
um as a side note here if you want to
learn more about language modeling I
think Alex lecture on this topic did you
give a guest lecture and Peter beale's
deep unsuprised learning class in 2020
is fantastic I think Alex does a great
job there explaining the history also
like language modeling leading up to
gpt2
um highly recommend so this was all the
perspective now from
um NLP let's look at computer version
because this is a little bit more close
to what I'm working on
um and actually the high level picture
there is very simple yeah
the question is what architecture works
best for computer version
and for almost 10 years we seem to have
a very clear answer to that which is
convolutional networks right this entire
recent deep learning wave started with
the Alex net breakthrough from the group
at Toronto where they demonstrated that
conflicts do very very well
and then for eight years basically
computer version plug confidence
everywhere got great games from that
um but in 2020
um people for the first time got similar
good performance with a very different
architecture in particular there's this
very nice version Transformers paper
from a group at Google brain in Zurich
and they figured out it's actually not
that hard to adapt the Transformer to be
a really good computer vision
architecture as well so what it was
whether you just you take the input
image you divide it into patches these
patches become the token for your
Transformer you have one linear
projection layer there and everything
else is just as the people can figure a
Transformer of the shelf and in some
benchmarks they even got better
performance in the state-of-the-art
confidence
then it was just back and forth or the
confidence the best or the version
Transformers the best interestingly the
same group at Google brain Zurich
shortly afterwards came out with yet
another architecture that again looks
quite different but actually is also
state of the art on the standard
benchmarks like classification the cool
thing about this was they call it an all
MLP architecture basically they wanted
something as simple as possible no more
self attention no more convolutions only
MLPs so fully connected layers and some
super basic operations specifically we
have layer normalizations or standard
normalization layer then the MLPs then
the very powerful transpose operation
and non-linearities so that's all the
burning parts
um and the funny thing is then okay like
what is best here this is claiming to be
best another thing is claiming to be
best in the same paper they did a very
interesting experiment or a very careful
experiment again looking at different
networks from this MLP mixer family the
Transformer and resonates and compare
them controlling for training compute so
yeah if Google is already ran on tpus
and then you see if your control for
compute they're actually kind of all the
same uh
maybe here the rest knife looks a little
bit brass and then you can say okay
maybe the resonates are a little
outdated now but turns out it's also not
true
um shortly thereafter there was a very
nice paper from fair and Berkeley where
they proposed are confident for the
2020s basically they looked at the last
so five years of confident
improvements figured out what really
worked put this all together into a new
architecture called corn of next and
then they outperformed the bits again
so overall in computer version the high
level of the story is Transformers are
not special there's a lot of back and
forth between different architectures
that sort of like too far at a high
level like MLP mixer vits continents but
the really important thing is actually
getting all the details of the training
recipe right you can make all of them
state of the art if you put in enough
experimentation to get the recipe
okay
um so let's go back to our question what
the llm revolution has happened without
Transformers so obviously we don't know
for sure no one has trained uh say gbt
3.5 or gpt4 level lstm and I don't think
anyone will in India time because we are
all bottlenecked on compute and it would
be a little bit silly to put all of this
compute right now into lstms but I think
overall the scaling evidence is pretty
good that you could get really high
quality llms also with recurrent neural
networks
look okay and we said while this is
maybe a more sort of like for an
experiment
it does tell us something our progress
in AI
yes
oh yeah people have used confidence for
language also um I'm not as much of an
expert they are
um
okay yeah it's a
paper from
now six or seven years ago
yeah someone showed that you could
actually get really good performance on
a lot of NLP tasks at the time like
sentiment classification text
classification
um with confidence as opposed to the
current neural networks
um
yeah this work from cursory school that
stands for they call it the hyena
architecture that has a convolution and
this is so more directly trying to be a
Transformer replacement I think it's a
great question whether you can do what
you can do with confidence and NLP I
think it also gets you surprisingly far
I don't know the exact experimental
details now the numbers it's a fantastic
question uh yeah I should put it in the
next version
yeah that's a fantastic question so
basically your question is all of these
scaling plots are always looking at per
okay this this one is different I mean
it doesn't have to apply well a computer
should not have perplexity but all of
these scaling law plots y-axis is always
perplexity for language modeling and
yeah no I mean this is a really good
point one should also hear the same
perplexity one should also look at
Downstream task accuracy I'm actually
one of the big proponents or often
points this out and people only show
perplexity having said that overall this
language modeling is basically the
trudge of let's improve complexity air
complexity and then it's like there's a
belief that if you make perplexity
better in the language models we will
get broadly better models
you're thinking business could break
down for this DMS yeah it might not be
true yeah
great question something to figure out
in the vision examples what were the
what was the metric was it equivalent of
perplexity oh yeah so Envision typically
the standard thing is people look at
image that accuracy as sort of like the
metric that this representative broadly
for
um
well like how could a model is and and
to be fair it is very well correlated
with a lot of other topics
yeah you may have the same concern which
is a valid concerned what about other
tasks if we only look at one maybe we
are underestimating the performance of
confidence or Transformers
So when you say that you know we've got
there another way I mean earlier pointed
out that long-range attention is key for
uh
um
you know but there's quite a lot of
interest now in trying to make
Transformers linear again like you know
in doing random vector projections or
various other threats dilated attention
however do you have a sense of sort of
how that would
have you know how you would have got the
long range how we could get long-range
attention from things like lstms uh you
know
or or conversely how we can get
transformed yeah great question you're
saying okay
um the Transformers are better at long
range dependencies than the lstms but I
don't think they're sort of like a clear
cut off and you can't get an lstm Beyond
a certain point the lstm if you make it
large enough will give you longer and
longer dependencies it's just I mean the
trust is underselling the aspect of
computational efficiency argument is all
about computational efficiency but it's
not a qualitative difference if you make
your lstms large enough the hypothesis
Elia has and this is also backed by some
of the data I showed so if you make the
lstns large enough you will get longer
and longer contexts
um you can actually look at this you
don't seem very confidence which is fair
I mean
you know I'm thinking of this there's
many domains in which you know the
Transformer nails
no no it's a great architecture yeah
yeah
yeah no no totally I mean
like do you have a specific domain in
mind well actually I'm thinking of
Genius so you know that's what
looking at models of genetic regulation
um
statement s
because
it's crazy
so I mean
could it could it be that it's just much
easier to train trainers yes no I think
this is actually one of the big
advantages of Transformers and to be
clear I don't want to make the claim you
should throw out the Transformer as I
said this is a very good invention I
still do think it's interesting to think
about is it actually the core piece of
llm specifically it may be the case that
for other domains Transformers are the
core piece
for now I'm interested in the question
or did a core piece for making high
quality language models that have all of
these like cool chat properties as well
yeah probably I think file sequences may
be the closest arguably the closest
example to the outside of language but
yes and so to go back to this
question of
uh like long ranges basically this plot
is not really answering it but it's sort
of like getting it as like here the 400k
parameter line
um plateaus as we said sort of like this
is evidence that the Transformers do
better as you go deeper into the context
um
if you make the lstm larger you get the
2 million line and the 200 million line
now the customers does this one plug two
earlier than this one I think it's a
little bit hard to read
there's more definitely more
experimentation needed
so when I was a grad student here I had
to take computer architecture
there's this enormous attention to the
details of you know fielsi and uh
uh speculation and you know pipelining
but then you know it became clear that
all of the factors of two and three that
you're winning this way you know you
wait a few years you know they're just
swapped by Moore's Law right and so I'm
wondering if this is if it's a similar
thing here that like if if your goal was
to beat a different you know a
AI company then you need all of these
things right but if you're interested in
the long-term progress that you don't I
think this is exactly how I think about
what happens
okay cool then let's continue all really
good questions
okay so what does this mean okay s
basically Scott just mentioned this one
way of thinking about all of these
algorithmic improvements is basically as
compute or data it's like when we invent
a Transformer this is super important
then we invent Adam this is super
important but this is not a qualitative
change this will allows us to get to
larger scale and scale is really all
that matters
um and when we compare these different
architectures in this solution and
computer version is the training recipe
really matters as much as the high level
architecture
and then depending on what we want to
understand when we talk of language
about language models some of this
understanding may have to be
architecture right so maybe one approach
is to say okay we specifically study
properties of the Transformer to
understand why language models have
certain immersion phenomena if the same
phenomena will also emerge as you push
an lstm to very large scale then maybe
this emergence is more Universal
look like pragmatically speaking at the
end I think one interesting question is
maybe if you want to improve elements we
should all just work at Nvidia because
if it's all about scales then the
problematically speaking a lot of the
progress in AI over the past 10 years
just depends on the video executing very
very well on your agenda of making
better than that they are accelerators
so you should just help them so here's
the Nvidia careers page
why not I'm not sponsored by a video
um cool okay so at some level this is
like the first half of the talk and we
could sort of like end here a couple
other speakers have already said this
um in the workshop AI is compute and
data we should really scale the compute
and the data very large and everything
will be great
um one thing that I always find a little
bit lacking
here is that as a community we have
spent a ton of time thinking about how
to do the algorithmic side here the
compute site better optimization
procedures better model architectures
better loss functions and so on this is
literally by now thousands of papers
every year and this was fantastic we're
learning a lot about this as we said
many times the Transformer is in the
Ender breakthrough if it's all about
scale getting a 10x or 100x on your
scaling is fantastic
um what I think is something sort of
missing is attention to the training
data because multiple speakers have
agreed that this is really key to all of
the story but we don't really talk about
it we just take this as given and then
um we talk about other things so what I
want to do in the second part of the
talk actually I don't know how many
minutes we have left
credit 40. okay good
um what I want to do in the second part
of the talk is tell you a little bit
more about my research where I try to
understanding data better but before I
do this
um just a little bit of background why I
think it is that we don't really do much
research on training data I think one
inherent
like limitation of this current
benchmarking Paradigm in machine
learning is that the data is always
fixed so first of all what do you mean
by the benchmarking Paradigm a lot of
empirical work in machine learning
basically follows this recipe we have a
some agreed on data sets that we think
are important and then the goal is to
push up the accuracy numbers or push
down the perplexity numbers on these
important data sets like this is one
example Ms Coco object detection data
set from computer version came out in
2015 and then the community has steadily
over time improved these models step by
step and as a result of that we know a
lot about four fixed object detection
training set like Ms Coco how do we push
up the numbers lots of very careful
ablation experiments it's great
um but never no one actually in this
framework tries a different training set
or like asks the question what should I
change in my Ms Coco training set in
order to have my model generalized
better so as a result that we have a few
papers experimenting with training data
and I'm not the only only one who's
asked us there's actually a quite nice
paper on this from Kai the computer
human interaction conference 2021
everyone wants to do the model work not
the data work data Cascades and high
stakes AI where they talk about some of
the reasons why people always want to
have a model stop on data and then
what's the effect of that Andrew Eng
started the data Centric AI resource Hub
in 2021
and in 2021 neurops also added the data
sets and Benchmark strikes specifically
to promote and highlight work on data
sets in benchmarks and this is quickly
growing this year 2023 there were
already more than 1 000 submissions to
the data sets in benchmark
so what I want to tell you now in the
second half of the targets just a bit
more emphasis and explanation for why I
think these data sets really really
matter specifically are the key for
Reliable generalization based on what
we've learned and
um Computer Learning and then the second
part of the talk what's going currently
going on in open source AI in order to
build better pre-training data
okay cool start with the first part and
since we don't have that much time left
I very quickly go through the motivation
machine learning research is great lots
of progress when you deployed in the
real world as other speakers also said
this Workshop it can be quite
challenging and one of the challenges is
that often these models are not
generalizing as reliably as they should
and this is still true in the era of
chatbots actually in a recent interview
Elia so let's give us that
his main hypothesis so if it's the case
that by 2030 mlms have not captured a
lot of economic value his hypothesis is
that the main bottleneck will be
reliability that you can sometimes do
amazing things but they can't do them
reliable enough so you can actually let
them access
okay and in order to understand this
better now we'll go to my favorite data
sets the imagenet has been as we said
very impactful and clarifying progress
with deep learning being really
important in computer version
I'm sure everyone has seen this it's a
large image classification data set 1
million training emerges 1 000 different
classes you can have an image of the
stock here and then you need to classify
it with golden retriever
many people have worked on this over 10
years but even at the very end when we
look at the distance of like 2018 2019
2020 the models were really really good
on image net but if you applied them to
other data distributions they were still
not as reliable as humans they're not as
reliable as we would like them to be and
then various researchers have made this
more precise by creating a range of out
of distribution tests so the idea being
you have a test set that has the same
class structure as image nut so you can
take an imagenet model and directly
evaluate it on your new test set without
any fine tuning you can just feed in the
images but they are something different
about this test distribution maybe the
crowd worker crowdsourcing process has
changed or you use a different modality
like sketches and so on and Berkeley is
actually very well represented in this
research Direction imagine that V2 and
imagenet are able from here
and then one way to
um sort of like understand what's going
on on these distribution shifts is by
just plotting what a lot of different
models do so let's look at this kind of
scatter plot x-axis imagenet this is
what I wanted to train on y-axis a
distribution shift let's start with
imagine at B2 and then I have plotted 80
different models here all of these Blue
Points of one standard emotional model
that we evaluated from the seminal
alexnet over vgt resnet all of these
file use architectures to the state of
the art at the time a version at B7
and then one thing that's interesting
here is all of these models closely
follow a linear Trend why that is a good
question for now we'll just take this as
a given and we'll use this as our
Baseline let's say someone invents a new
neural network Umesh comes up with
Uber's net and umergenet gets 71 on
average net and then
um you would like to understand if
umishnet is more reliable than existing
networks and then we can see okay 71
let's go to our Baseline on imagenet B2
we would expect 58 accuracy and then if
um gets 58 accuracy we think okay that's
good but roughly basically what we would
expect based on prior what we're really
after is a network that's above this red
line here
um why is this the goal because we know
that humans have this property we did an
experiment where you and extra labelers
classified imaginary emergency V2 and
then humans are exactly on the stashed
line by equal signs so humans are not
affected by this distribution
tool the image electron networks are or
do any models achieve what we call a
factor for muscles so there will be
above this red line
there are the humans change on
it's a good question yeah
humans are on the line okay no there
some of them are really a little bit
below the line like one percent and this
is because image that B2 is in the it's
a little bit more noisy a little bit
more noisy this is why we did this
experiment because we wanted to know how
much more noisy but you don't like
changing I mean you need to tell the
humans a thousand classes actually it's
a total pain like never do this so we
can learn more about this later but at
home hours later but you need like
it is not a natural task in the end to
classify emergency one of a thousand
categories if you know what a tiger
beetle is like
yeah well like you notice when you do
this yeah like 130 dog breeds it's
pretty bad anyway
am I understanding this graph correctly
that the best models are matching the
humans out of distribution by beating
the humans yeah great point we cut off
this plot plot a little bit too low the
humans actually when we did this the
humans match the best networks and image
not an outperform them on image
the best models did as well as sorry the
best humans that as well as the best
models on imagenet or even a little bit
better but not much but they definitely
noticeably outperform them on imaginary
tool I see all right got it thanks
okay questions now the next point is
okay people have worked a lot on
robustness to distribution shift and
there have been many more models some of
them not trained on imagenet let's see
how well they do in the strength and
this is what we did we basically ran
another about 100 models and we added
them to this plot and your first sort of
like thought here maybe this just looks
like the same plot Ludwig and this is
indeed the right reaction and basically
we have the brown models here
um which are all very close to the red
line so these are models trained with
adversarial training randomized
smoothing so all the things that people
came up with in the context of adversial
robustness special forms of data
augmentation and so on
um the only models that really stand out
are the models trained on more data so
I've highlighted not all of them but
some of them are above the red line I've
highlighted three of them the top right
one is our experiment from Google they
trained on 300 million images in an
internal data set then we have a couple
of data points from Facebook where they
train on an internal data set of 1
billion images and then one model that
was trained on the full image net so 10
to 20 million if these data points are
indeed above the line
um by a little bit like one to two
percentage points you can look at this a
little bit like glasses half full the
glass is half empty
um at least there's some signal there
a bit more data helps and we'll see in a
minute this was indeed the right
intuition to happen
yeah a great Point these green points
are pre-trained on other data sets and
then they are fine-tuned languages
and this was all now in the context of
Imagine a D2 so you could pay oh I mean
maybe two maybe we should also look at
other data sets so we did this object
net I had no involvement in and object
net now has a much larger drop
um 40 percentage Point overall still are
quite nice linear Trend and the models
that stand out in the top right corner
here in the higher accuracy regime are
the models trained on more data I guess
and there's a lot more experiments we
have done like that and there's a lot
more to say here but in the interest of
time I want to tell you what really made
a lot of progress here and this was the
clip model from open AI just came out in
um connecting text and images they had a
big release for multi-modal learning
clip and Dolly came out on the same day
and the cool thing was that in the blog
post and in the paper where they are now
in the club they exactly evaluated their
models in our robustness framework so
they took their largest clip model a
club vitl get 76 percentage Point 76.2
percent on imagenet We compare that to
an imagenetrained resonate 101 same
accuracy and then basically same
accuracy means in our scatter plot we
had the same x-axis value so when we
look at this out of distribution test
sets
um what we are doing is we're looking
exactly at effective robustness so and
then clip gets plus six percent
on imagenet V2 plus 51 on imagenet R
plus 40 on object net plus 35 on image
in its catch plus 74 on one more data
set that we haven't talked about yet
imagine it and these are very large
dates
um if your bargain these images like
data sets sort of like single digit
Improvement small single digit
improvements are something you happily
write a paper about and they came out
with large double digit improvements and
so like the plus six on average 92 which
is pretty small this is still half of
the drop so much more than we've seen
before it's like one nice
um point to mention also here's the way
you said open AI this is a little bit
abstract the guy who invented this is
again I like Rockford so he invented GPT
and then he was like cool I invented GPT
now let's look at distribution shift and
then he made a lot of progress on that
okay cool and these are have become very
widely used models yesterday I checked
on the hugging phase model repository
and the third most commonly downloaded
model on hugging face is one of the open
air models this was the most widely used
computer version model on hugging face
because I mean So intuitively speaking
once you have these robustness
properties
this becomes a much more useful model
just the use of the Shelf you don't need
to worry that much about like oh my data
distribution is different do I need to
fine tune often trust a clip off the
shelf is a really good starting point
um and then let's look at this again in
our scatter plot visualization
um x-axis imagenet so the the same as we
did before by access distribution shift
in average over seven of them blue line
is the original trade models the green
points where the prior more data models
and then the orange line here is clip in
zero shot mode so clip roughly closed
half of the gap between the prior models
and the dashed Y equals X line on D7
distribution so as I said this was super
impressive to me and this made me think
okay what makes the clip models more
robust there's a second interesting
Insight here this goes to fine tuning
what Greg just mentioned if you take the
clip models and you fine-tune them then
you get the red line and the red line
isn't actually that much better than the
prior green points now keep in mind all
of these three points will fine-tuned so
one important takeaway here was fine
tuning actually erases a lot of your
robustness
and
all of these models were fine-tuned so
we actually never know how good could
these models have been if they had used
them in the zero shot evaluation the
other big question coming out of this
can you do fine tuning while preserving
the robustness and the answer to the
second question is yes but we don't have
Target time to talk about this this was
my first paper of collaborators at UW we
are now going to look at where the
robustness comes from again
um not super much time to talk about the
details here but at a high level the
title of this paper gives it away data
determines distributional robustness and
contrastive language image pre-training
so what we did in this paper was
basically go through a lot of different
hypotheses set up experiments to test
each of them and see bots left basically
so one obvious hypothesis is language
supervision the whole point of clip was
connecting text and images you can now
do language supervision
for computer version another obvious
Contender was the training distribution
because it's a different fan
distribution and then the others we are
training that size let's train on more
images loss function contrast versus
supervised for most of the imagenet
models test time prompting is something
you can do with club and model
architecture so the best club model so
Vision Transformers the best imagenet
models before that we are confident what
we do in this paper is we go through all
of them and this nice thing is this
comes out very crisply like really all
of the robustness in this effect of
robustness framework comes from the
training District
yes
so I guess it seems like when you say
the training distribution it's not just
like the amount of data but the actual
great point so doesn't that over
English supervision because like
language being in the training
distribution is part of
yeah okay let me be a little bit more
precise so it's a really great question
thanks Jacob so let me first clarify
what do I mean by training distribution
versus trainings that size if we go back
to our Scatter Plots here you can ask
the question what happens if I just had
more or less original training data that
and what we did to test this was we just
put imagine it and we subsampled
imagenet by a factor 248 1632 and the
interesting thing is as you vary the
amount of data you have from imagenet
you're moving exactly along the red line
like as you have less and less training
data you get to pretty low accuracy but
it's always staying on the same line so
this is why intuitively speaking and the
linear Trend you're on is a function of
the training distribution and this is
why we can separate training
distribution from training set size so
now to talk about language superversion
versus training distribution what we did
here was the following and we took a
merch net and then we added language
supervision so the nice thing about
imagenet is imagenet was built from our
web data source that had looked like
annotations because specifically
immature was built from Flickr and
basically what we did was do all the
data wrangling to connect half of
imagenet back to the original flicker
sources then we cook at the human
version captions from Flickr put this
together as a imagenet training set with
a training Distribution on the image
side is imagenet but now we have the
language supervision also and that gives
you zero robustness
there's more experiments all of the
other way can you take an image Text
data set where you are more robust and
throw away the text and be more robust
in the answers yes
okay
um cool so this was basically what
really convinced me that we need to
understand trainings that's better
because I had worked on this out of
distribution shifts for quite a while
nothing really seemed to help and then
clip just blew everything out of the
world
um cool so there's more to say with tax
guided image generation that we don't
have time for that so let me tell you a
little bit about what we are doing to
build better pre-training data sets yeah
I mean uh so no idea what puts machine
on but like it uh
yeah to start you download all the
publicly available image data sets
no that would be pretty bad Okay so
and we know that this is not the answer
but
um okay so there's two like the three
levels of overlap here first level of
overlap would be you actually train on
the object Network original V2 tested
that would be extremely bad that that's
not happening the next level will be you
train on the original training set
and some other curated computer vision
training set it's also not happening so
like how do we know this well I asked
and that's what they told me now you
could say maybe you don't trust them but
in our own reproductions later we know
what we trained on we remove the
training their duplicates and it's fun
now the third level is like what about
some more vague notion of semantic
overlap maybe one of the data sets we
looked at this image let's catch maybe
in your Club pre-training data you have
a lot more sketches and I think this is
definitely part of what's going on in
fact I think this is largely what's
going on that there's some notion of
coverage that I can't tell you precisely
what it is because we just know numbers
go up and I think this notion of
coverage in the end determines our
distribution generalization and the
algorithmic improvements are orthogonal
to that
like what aspect of this distribution of
training helps or no so because the
problem was the trend the club trainings
that is public to open AI so after this
came out basically step one for us in
the open source Community was just let's
reproduce a training set of that scale
so we can actually do comparable
experiments so this is what I'm going to
tell you next this is the lion 5B data
set so this was a big open source
collaboration with lots of people from
lots of different institutions and
that's the name suggests this is a data
set of five billion image taxpayers and
in retrospect we realized we actually
had six billion image taxpayers but
since this was a very distributed effort
and it's been quite propagate through
through the group of authors that we in
the end had six really much textures on
5.9 doesn't really matter it's a lot of
image taxpayers and specifically it's
about 50 times more data than the
previous state of the art and public
data sets so before lion there was this
yfcc 100 million data set with 100
million image taxpayers and then ours is
50 times larger than the prior state of
the art and this gets you in the same
ballpark as the private data sets at
places like Google and open AI
okay and to tell you a little bit about
how this was built let's look at
this graphic here okay we start with a
large candidate pool specifically common
crawl that's 50 billion image taxpayers
then we do some filtering of the web
pages specifically we take only images
that haven't Associated audit text right
if you know HTML image tags and HTML can
have an other text that's displayed when
the image is not visible
and this is what we use as raw source of
image text pair data and this is very
very noisy so what we do is one
processing step is we actually use open
AIS Club model
vatp32 to do some filtering we feed the
image through the image encoder text
through the text encoder look at the
cosine similarity and if the cosine
similarity is above a certain threshold
then we keep the example otherwise
this was our first step of building a
large image Text data set and there are
lots of questions around this step like
one concern I had was oh if we use a b32
for filtering maybe you can't get better
than a b32 model when you train on the
status and fortunately this did not turn
out to be the case you could actually
train pretty good models on this so
let's look at two comparisons
um smaller clip model p32 version
Transformer open Ai and lion two
different models we trained basically
the same accuracy like 0.4.3 percentage
points less
um this was this is really good and
overall lion has become a wide use data
set I'm sure everyone has heard about
stable diffusion the image generation
models they were all trained online
as we scaled up the club models we saw
an increasingly large gap between what
we could get with the lion data set and
what we could
get what the open AI model achieved so
an imagenet an l14 Club is about three
percentage points worth
um then the open AI model and then the
lion train clip on object net is nine
percentage Point worse than the Open Air
Model and this was a bit of a bummer for
me because I got so excited about the
club models because of the nice out of
distribution properties and now hundreds
out of distribution tested object net
suddenly clip our club train on lion is
first so the next obvious question of
the lion was can we improve lie on and
this is now where I would like to have
all the insights Greg is asking for
because hopefully we can do this in a
more principled way and so for like what
we did is a step in this direction now
as our next large open source
collaboration is data comp so the data
comp stands for data set competition and
the ideas here basically let's flip
around the standard machine learning
Paradigm as a benchmarking Paradigm as I
mentioned at the beginning currently
this is like fixed training set
researchers iterate on the modeling side
like that loss functions Network
architectures optimization algorithms
but training data always stays fixed so
in data.com you say okay let's flip this
around we'll give you training code the
model training code is fixed you are
supposed to improve the final model by
improving the training set
and the whole bus if we do this and more
people join us then we'll get a similar
collaborative research process our data
sets as we also have around model
Centric AI research okay well what was
the budget rely on
my almost done extremely cheap
um like this is also like now now we
have a bit more resources but
uh like some of the people in this open
source are extremely resourceful like
they found like a cheap deal on a
Chinese Cloud where you could get a CPU
node for like one dollar per month and
they got as many of them as they could
it was it was very very I mean you could
be boasting right there on the
shoestring budget
only three to nine points but you know
oh yeah I'm going to Boston but wait for
it
um
when we are really there
um okay good
um thanks for the encouragement
um good so let's let's continue because
we don't have that much time left I do
want to get to the point where I can
post
um okay so what do we do as part of
date.com one aspect of data set research
is the bariatric entry is substantially
higher because if you want to improve on
someone's model you download their
pytorch code you change five lines and
you're halfway to your next Ikea paper
for data set research
um
you download someone's data set but you
don't have any of the tooling that
people have built internally to actually
curate the data set like typically a
data set release like Ms coco or
imagenet it's a data dump but none of
the surrounding tooling so what we
basically did with data Converse we do
lion from scratch but now in a fully
reproducible way it can be basically
provided cool so you can easily build
your own layer and in order to make this
as simple as possible we provide a large
data pool of image text pairs the larger
scale 12.8 billion emerge taxpayers we
realize this is a lot so we go down by a
factor of 10 three times so the smallest
scale here the compute you need is like
fine-tuning an image this is really
something every academic group can do
this is more like training and emotional
model from scratch at 128 million scale
which is still within the reach of most
academic groups okay so this is what we
provide with some clip training code and
then as a participant you can
submit either a new subset a subset of
our pool that we provide this is the
filtering track that you basically
propose a better filtering method to go
from an uncurated web scale data set to
an actual clip training set or you say
okay I don't like your common crawl pool
and you come with your new own data
source this is to bring your own data
good so this is sort of like what we
built there's an obvious question can
you actually make progress in this
framework and we very much wanted to
notice ourselves so we provided also a
baseline data set with some simple
techniques in this data.com framework
and this is our new data comp training
set and let's compare this to the open
Ai and lion training that's and the nice
thing is now the outcome we outperform
the open AI training set by four
percentage points on imagenet and by
five percentage points on object net
especially now if you look compared to
Lion an object that we see of 14
percentage Point Improvement which is a
lot
and now to follow
um Scott's encouragement I'm going to
post the first Public Training set is
better than the virtual open AI and this
is already in use at places like
anthropic Apple researchers from CU have
used that researchers and meta and so on
and one interesting way of looking at
this as we mentioned earlier the key
really in all of this is scale in
particular we should always think of
improvements in terms of compute
multiplier and when you do this here you
this data set Improvement that we get
from data come over lion is a 9x compute
Improvement you could already push a
club model to 79 accuracy on Lion but
you needed to make the model a lot
larger and train it for a lot longer so
this costs nine times more than what you
now need for if data come to get the
same 79 percent
researchers have already built on data
the current state-of-the-art models at
least the publicly available ones are
trained on data
and
then in April I got this very nice email
from a researcher at anthropic and the
Chance where he wanted to send us some
gift baskets as a thank you for the C4
and data comp Early Access and as a poor
academic I'm always happy when people
send me gift cards
cool okay so now we are basically out of
time
Next Level next level for now I'm okay
with content
um cool
um we could talk a little bit more about
what we do to make this data set better
I do not want to claim we have any
principle Instead This was pretty hecky
overall I just want to see Can we is
there room for improvement and I hope
that now we and others can build on this
to do more controlled experiments and
understand what is really important on
these pre-training data sets one thing
that I think is worth highlighting is
again the importance of scaling goals
right at the very beginning of the talk
we started oh scanning all super
important because model development is
expensive and this is exactly how we
went about data comp because as Scott
mentioned you do need a budget for these
things and the budget is never large
enough so you need to be a little bit
thoughtful so what we did as I mentioned
we had these different scales and data
comp large medium and small that's what
I highlighted here and every Point here
in this plot is one filtering method and
now you can correlate how well does a
filtering method do on the small scale
of data comp versus the medium scale how
well does a filtering method do on the
medium scale of data comp versus the
large scale and these Scatter Plots are
imperfect but they're pretty good so
basically what we did in order to come
up with the state-of-the-art data set
was I think 70 of our experiments were
on small and medium scale then a couple
of them at large scale and only a very
small number at the extra large scale at
the end all of this experimentation for
what filtering works best was done on
small ones and the idea was okay if it
does better on a small or medium scale
that hopefully also does better than its
largest and by and large should work
pretty well
cool there's more right now from others
like a DT and sqls group at CMU they
started working on this and got some
nice improvements recently what we are
currently doing is basically the same
thing but for llms because same store in
LMS we need better free training data
sets but in the interest of time let's
conclude so first part of the talk was
okay AI is compute and data lots of
important Innovations on the compute
side I think can be unified by thinking
of them as compute multipliers how much
more efficient are we becoming in
training large language models
and then the Transformer is super
important but in the end if you are just
looking at one language maybe it's
really just a big computer Improvement
um
architectures can very much have
advantages Beyond compute I think
multimodality is one example where
Transformers really shine
next point then was okay we talked about
the compute half of the AI thing the
data side side
at least based on the experiments we've
seen large data sets are really
important for Reliable generalization
yes they're also behind all of these
improvements in text generation sorry
image generation text guided image
generation and this is again an example
where the exact architecture actually
doesn't it like all of these exciting
advances and image generation typically
people think of them as diffusion models
you can get exactly the same quality
basically out of Standard Auto
regressive models if you choose the next
token prediction in the image space
you'll get Just As Nice emerged as a
stable diffusion
okay and then the final point was
current data sets are still assembled in
a rather ad hoc way I think there's a
lot of scope for improving their
training saturation processes cool so
now you have 30 seconds left thanks a
lot
we have a little bit of time for
questions
um do you have any comment on like the
successful data filtering or like new
sources that like allowed particular
data sets to be more successful
um no it's a great question so you could
ask okay very completely here how is
data combated and lion
um it's not the source both of them are
from command crawl
um I think there's room for improvement
by adding more data sources but to keep
things simple we just wanted to see how
much can we improved staying within the
same data source
um basically what we did here was
um fine-tuning the clip filtering then
we threw out English language filtering
so which was a little bit funny right
all of the downstream evaluation tasks
are English so it seemed like English
filtering is maybe a good idea so you
have more English content and turns out
if you take it out things get better
um I think intuitively this is because
language filtering is not as clear-cut
as it seems you have a picture of Paris
caption is Paris is this English French
or German
and in the end the clip model knows well
enough if it understands the caption or
not
um and then the third thing was we added
an image quality filter again in a
somewhat Hardware
I'm very curious to see what other
people
any other questions
yeah maybe also thanks for the nice talk
um yeah maybe just to follow up on that
I guess sort of in general if I were you
know constructing a data set you know
based on the intuition you've got from
doing this like what are kind of like
the first order important features I
should keep in mind for what would make
it good
I mean I think first order again the
scale is really important so let's try
to get as many image taxpayers as
possible at some point it becomes
computationally expensive and then you
want to do your application studies at
small scale but first order more data is
better
more diverse data sources are probably a
good idea and initially we thought this
was one of the reasons why the openai
data set is better because they use more
than just common crawl but now we all
perform them by doing just common call
so I'm actually not sure it depends a
bit like if you care about performance
on a certain domain you should get more
data from the domain what is more
general purpose data sets unclear at the
moment
um yeah I guess I mean so go ahead oh
yeah I guess like maybe part of what I'm
wondering is like I think I have the
same intuition that more diverse is
better but then if we're kind of like
maximally diverse with the uniform
distribution which like usually is not
good so kind of like
Jacob
it's a great question
um
some notion of coverage you're right you
also don't want the uniform distribution
in the sense like we don't want gaussian
images in there
um I think for now the thing that works
well is just like be very metric driven
like set up a process where all of the
Innovations you come up with you very
carefully measure the improvements if
they actually check out and then things
do stack over time
cool thank you
oh I was just going to ask you do you
have a sense for how um
um how one can do fine-tuning without
without uh oh yeah this is a great
question and the nice thing is this is
very easy to explain because it's
um
so in this paper where it was the
following so you have your pre-trained
model with good robustness but not so
good Downstream task performance you
have your fine-tuned model with meteoric
robustness but Downstream task
performance you take the two weights you
add them up and that's it
the average between certain predictions
okay you can also average and prediction
space but that problem that's that's
ensembling the problem with ensembling
is that now you have two models that
inference time it's a little bit messy
because they're already expensive so be
very curious can we get sort of like
fine tuning without any computational
overhead it helps time and the answer is
you can get this by really just
averaging the weights it's a little bit
silly the first time I saw this I was
like
um but so far we have not found anything
better so the first time I thought I saw
this I thought like okay great the
signal here you can make better and if
we do like something more rigorous
optimization based we will outperform it
we have not managed to outperform it
uh no there's obviously the 30 pages of
experiments so you compared to baselines
and like try all the different data sets
but like the actual algorithm is one
language
if there are no other questions uh let's
thank Lulu once again
[Applause]
foreign